[Music]
jennifer lopez and ben affleck are tying
the knot over a year after rekindling
their romance affleck popped the
question for a second time i give it
away but it has a very good ending jlo
shared their engagement news on friday
and let's just say she's feeling lucky
i'm ready i'm excited about it as lopez
explains her green engagement ring is a
full circle moment
[Music]
lopez gave fans an intimate look into
her life in a short clip from her
newsletter titled on the jlo she goes on
to say green is her favorite color which
is on brand with her ever so iconic
versace dress lopez's ensemble stole the
entire show at the 2000 grammy awards
tell me first off with this outfit
versace i saw donatello with it and i
had to have it for the grammys years
later she believes the color has always
been a good luck charm lopez writes
quote i've realized there are many
moments in my life where amazing things
happen when i was wearing green
it may be a coincidence
maybe not
but as i took a better look i realized
there are no coincidences and there's
been plenty of hints leading up to her
big news
so i have a really
um
exciting
and special story to share lopez teased
the announcement on friday also adding
an engagement ring emoji to her twitter
handle
but she first kicked off engagement
rumors last week when lopez was spotted
wearing the ring while shopping with
daughter emmy
and the engagement caps off a world win
year for bennefer 2.0 you know it's wild
to think about it that way following
multiple sightings of the couple packing
on the pda they became instagram
official in july
[Applause]
lopez and affleck made their red carpet
comeback in september with the singer
supporting her love at the last duel
premiere it was their first movie
premiere appearance since 2003's jeely i
think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working but
even more recently aflac has been
returning the favor he walked the carpet
with jlo at the merry meet premiere in
february where she remained tight-lipped
about wedding plans i would be remiss if
i didn't say you were standing taking
photos in front of a sign that says
marry me it's very big i didn't really
realize how big
[Music]